Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Mesi spesi ad aspettare un tuo movimento,
un tuo gesto, un tuo segno,
un avvertimento.
Giorni persi a soffocare
un'apatia solo mia.
Sono sempre più convinto
che mi serva un'idea
perché da solo passo i giorni a letto,
perché da solo sono solo marea
e tu la luna che aspetto.
Un'idea, un'idea
che pulisca il cielo e segni la via.
perché c'è solo nebbia che non va via.
Un'idea, un'idea
che pulisca il cielo e segni la via.
perché c'è solo nebbia che non va via.
Un'idea che serva per risollevare il peso
dell'attesa luce accesa
su un rapporto chiuso
Un'idea anche brutta,
anche stupida o banale
che sia efficace che mi dica sei capace,
una condizione
che mi faccia stare al mondo
che mi porti salvo
in fondo a questo lungo inverno
quell'idea
che mi permetta giorno dopo giorno
di godermi l'attimo
e non pensare all'eterno.
Ma aiutami! Soccorrimi! Ascoltami!
Ti aspetto qui...
Sono spento come il mare senza cormorani,
come un'Italia senza gli artigiani.
Un'idea, un'idea
che pulisca il cielo e segni la via.
Un'idea, un'idea,
perché c'è solo nebbia che non va via.
Un'idea, un'idea
che pulisca il cielo e segni la via.
Un'idea, un'idea,
perché c'è solo nebbia che non va via.
Un'idea che riesca a farmi parlare,
un'idea che dia una luce al colore,
uno schiaffo, un insulto,
una spinta, un bel salto,
un'idea che dia una voce
a ciò che non sento.
Quell'idea, che già mi ha fatto volare.
Quell'idea, che già mi ha fatto volere.
Un'idea che demolisca i miei muri
che abbassi le mie cerniere.
Un'idea, un'idea
che pulisca il cielo e segni la via.
perché c'è solo nebbia che non va via.
Un'idea, un'idea
che pulisca il cielo e segni la via.
perché c'è solo nebbia che non va via.
(Applausi)
Grazie, io sono Francesco Camin
ed è un piacere essere qua,
partecipe a questo evento.
Il prossimo brano che vi faccio ascoltare
si intitola "Sospesi".
Ci son cose che mi domando,
ma non rispondo.
Cose strane,
milioni di rane in sottofondo.
Dubbi scuri che sono muri,
che non so abbattere senza te.
Mi domando
perché d'inverno il ramo è spoglio.
E d'estate le sue giornate
le veste al meglio.
Tu accarezzavi e poi
non ti stancavi mai
e adesso come fai
a disegnare noi?
Colori non ne vuoi;
è troppo tardi ormai...
Cosa spinge quel fiore bianco
a morire in frutto.
Mi sorridevi e me lo spiegavi
sdraiati su un tetto.
Ma ora se dico "noi" la sua eco è "mai".
E adesso come fai
a disegnare noi?
Colori non ne vuoi:
è troppo tardi ormai...
Risposte perdute come il sole d'autunno
come foglie cadute
su un amore e il suo inganno,
come neve in Aprile,
come i giochi in cortile
come un treno che parte
ma non sa dove andare
e ora sono distanti gli istanti tra noi.
per scoprire chi sei e capire
che è troppo tardi ormai.
Adesso come fai
a disegnare noi?
Colori non ne vuoi:
è troppo tardi ormai...
(Applausi)
Grazie, molte grazie.